- [Instructor] We're told
that given the height h
and volume V of a certain cylinder,
Jill uses the formula r is equal
to the square root of V over pi h
to compute its radius to be 20 meters.
If a second cylinder has the
same volume of the first,
but is 100 times taller,
what is its radius?
Pause this video,
and see if you can figure
this out on your own.
All right, now let's do this together.
So first, I always like to
approach things intuitively.
So let's say the first cylinder
looks something like this,
like this.
And then the second cylinder,
here, it's 100 times taller.
I would have trouble drawing something
that's 100 times taller.
But if it has the same volume,
it's going to have to be a lot thinner.
So if you want to maintain the volume,
as you make the cylinder taller,
and I'm not going anywhere
close to 100 times as tall here,
you're going to have
to decrease the radius.
So we would expect a radius
to be a good bit less than 20 meters.
So that's just the first intuition,
just to make sure that we
somehow don't get some number
that's larger than 20 meters.
But how do we figure
out what that could be?
Well, now we can go back to the formula,
and we know that Jill calculated
that 20 meters is the radius.
So 20 is equal to the
square root of V over pi h.
And if this formula
looks unfamiliar to you,
just remember the volume of a cylinder is
the area of either the top or the bottom,
so pi r squared times the height.
And if you were to just solve this for r,
you would have this exact
formula that Jill uses.
So this isn't some new formula.
This is probably something
that you have seen already.
So we know that 20
meters is equal to this,
and now we're talking about a situation
where we're at a height
that is 100 times taller.
So this other cylinder
is going to have a radius
of square root of,
V is going to be the same,
so let's just write that V there.
Pi doesn't change.
It's always going to be pi.
And now instead of h,
we have something that
is 100 times taller.
So we could write that as 100h.
And then what's another way to write this?
Well, what I'm going to do
is try to bring out the 100,
so I still get the square
root of V over pi h.
So I could rewrite this
as the square root of
one over 100
times V over pi h,
which I could write as the
square root of one over 100,
and I'm just using
properties of radicals here,
times the square root
of V over pi h.
Now, we know what the square
root of V over pi h is.
We know that that is 20,
and our units are in meters.
So this is 20.
And then what's the square
root of one over 100?
Well, this is the same thing
as one over the square root of 100.
And of course, now it's
going to be times 20,
times 20.
Well, the square root of 100,
I should say the principal
root of 100 is 10.
So the radius of our new cylinder,
of the second cylinder is
going to be 1/10 of 20,
which is equal to two meters.
And we're done.
The second cylinder is going
to have a radius of two meters,
which meets our intuition.
If we increase our height
by a factor of 100,
then our radius decreases
by a factor of 10.
The reason why is
because you square the
radius right over here.
So if height increases by a factor of 100,
if radius just decreases
by a factor of 10,
it'll make this whole expression
still have the same volume.